NICE
Sleeping Relaxing Music, ne ne ne, das da vielleicht, ah das ist nice, das passt, das
passt gut zu Bastlostream.
Oh, ich seh grad gar nicht, jetzt seh ich den Chat hier auch, nice, Leute, warte mal,
Windows 10 will starten, ne ne ne, Windows, muss ich das wirklich anlocken, dabei will
ich Windows 10 gar nicht starten, äh, Windows 11, ah, Poggers will ich starten, Poggers,
hier, Leute, moin, whoop, arrive, guck mal, der Raspberry Pi ist dreckig hier, den müssen
wir mal ein bisschen, mal ein bisschen sauber machen, so, gleich, gleich besser aus, so,
jetzt muss ich nur noch checken, ob Twitch es gecheckt hat, dass der Stream on ist, weil
aktuell siehts nicht so aus, nix im Chat los, gar nix, wait, mal update in der Zwischenzeit
startet nix, ah ja, jetzt, das weiß ich nicht genau, kommt drauf an, wie blöd man ist, ja,
jetzt 35, ich glaub, jetzt hat's Twitch, glaub ich, gecheckt, okay, whoop, arrive, yes, ja,
mach mal update, mach mal update, düt, düt, düt, düt, düt, das ist mir doch ein bisschen
zu anstrengend, Mario Kart Mix, da gibt's auch bestimmt was gescheites, sowas hier, jawoll,
genau, massive, leonardbomber97, danke für den Sub, China Geräte flashen wird heute gemacht
und in der Zwischenzeit, bis das Stream richtig on ist, werde ich mal mein OS aktualisieren,
dann zeig ich euch, was ich am Start hab, was geflasht wird, nicht so schnell, ist jemand
im Discord, hat es der Cutebot schon mitgekriegt, dass der Stream on ist, wenn nicht, warten
wir einfach noch kurz, ich hab mir ein paar Sachen bestellt bei Amazon, ne, stimmt überhaupt
nicht, das labe ich für'n Scheiß, nicht bei Amazon, bei Aliexpress, zeig ich euch gleich,
ich glaube, ich könnte die Kamera noch ein bisschen, guck mal, ich könnte die Kamera
noch ein bisschen hier hin drehen, oder, mein, warte mal, hier ist der Rand, naja, nö, eigentlich
ist alles drauf, so mehr oder weniger, ah, zum größten Teil ist alles drauf, passt
schon, der Cutebot hat's noch nicht gecheckt, ok, naja, kann man nix machen, Cutebot Anzeige
ist raus, oh, wo hab ich denn mein Tablet, Tablet ist nicht da, ich wollte auf dem Tablet
Twitch Vorschau machen, dass ich nix übersehe, Sack, oh ne, ich bin nicht ein, oh Gott,
Twitch, Alter, null, nicht eingeloggt, da muss ich den Browser aufmachen, Corona Time,
so, wo bloß, Twitch, wo bloß, Twitch, so, guck ob das jetzt funktioniert oder, natürlich
macht er nur die App auf, der Drecksack, man, so, jetzt geht's glaub ich, jetzt geht's
glaub ich, dann seh ich's halt im Browser, das macht ja nix, Hauptsache, ich seh was,
Tabletspielen, Wupp League, ja, ah, guckt jetzt, guckt jetzt, funzt, sag's euch, jetzt
funzt, Stream, Streamception, Alter, ok, so ist gut, so ist gut, dann stell ich mir das
hier hinten irgendwo hin, dass ich das sehe, weil ich muss ja den Chat sehen, oh, was jetzt,
was jetzt, ist down, but why, äh, irgendwie hat er das Display ausgeschaltet, was machen
wir jetzt, ich muss jetzt, Big Brain Time, er hat das Display geloggt, ich weiß nicht
warum, vielleicht bin ich vom Abend rangekommen oder so, ich muss jetzt auf den Stuhl klettern,
dass ich Facetime entsperren kann, das wird was, Achtung, ok, aufs Bauenpfeil, ach, noch
ein bisschen, ok, ich hab's, ich hab's, ich hab's, ich hab's, ich hab's, ich hab's, ich
hab's, ok, egal, vielleicht habe ich gerade ausgeschaltet, keine Ahnung, Sie wissen ja,
das ich wüsste nicht wie aber aber gut so jetzt habe ich mein tablet hier oben stehen
jetzt sehe ich euch nämlich so dahinter mir handlig jawoll wie streamt max seine cam
übers iphone obs ninja eigentlich richtig nice obs ninja github projekt obs ninja
erreicht jetzt vdo ninja ok gut alles klar damit kann man das über den browser machen
ist eigentlich ganz gut das einzige dass es rum backt mit ios man braucht custom
parameter für ios aber ansonsten ist eigentlich wirklich in ordnung ich habe im prinzip das video
was ich letztens letztens hatte also mehr kann man da eigentlich nicht zu sagen so was sind das
jetzt sofort halt controls jawoll also ich zeige euch mal was ich heute am start habe also erste
mal wenn du jetzt den raspberry pi 4 brauchen wir auf jeden fall wir haben hier dieses poggers
gehäuse das ist kann ich übrigens jedem nur empfehlen ich werde öfters hier im stream mal
gefragt wie was welches gehäuse wird empfehlen von raspberry pi 4 das da das ist das flier case
oder flier case wie auch immer hier übrigens katzen katzen stells so und das ist quasi so ein
kompletter block aus aluminium würde ich sagen und innen drinne ist so was das geht direkt auf die
cpu vom raspberry pi und dann geht die verteiltes die hitze quasi über das komplette gehäuse an
der seite das wirklich nicht schlecht so einmal raspberry pi den brauchen wir heute zum flaschen
kappa bright netzwerkabel passen dafür und jetzt zeige ich euch mal was leute den small small small
small access point gucken euch an miniature access point small access point und passendes
small kabel ich meine die sehen nur wie gemacht füreinander aus oder cute access point ja ist
echt so cute access point das ist kein sonderlich advance access point aber für solche bastel ein
ist das genau das richtige weil ich wollte euch beim flaschen mal ein bisschen mehr zeigen als
als das flaschen und dann das webinterface ich kann euch heute mit dem access point den kompletten
weg zeigen also ich kann das kabel ist zu lang ja finde ich auch das ist ganz schön mit wird eng
kann ich euch den kompletten weg zeigen den dhcp server wie sich das ding ip sucht also dann das
gerät was die die geräte die wir flaschen alles hier drüber das ist ein mikrotik access point
kostet 25 euro oder so die dinger sind ultra billig und zum basteln ist das eigentlich optimal
warte mal uap light ne nicht uap mikrotik ap light ich kriege kein geld von mikrotik also
kauft es euch nicht wartet auf mein sponsorship nein das ist das falsche
ap light wie ist denn das wie heißt wie heißt das teil map map light heißt es map map light ja
ganz kleiner mini furz access point 25 euro leute 25 euro da kann man wirklich zu viel verkehrt mal
für 25 euro wir probieren jetzt noch mal was anderes aus wir müssen mal gucken ob ich das
hier mit dem overlay noch hin bekomme schauen wir mal zack alles bei mir lokal gehostet also hier
hacker man sind wahrscheinlich schon wieder drin habe ich recht hätte mein chat firefox pepega
style so machen wir das hier mal auf aber das hier auf hallo hallo wo wo was das lag fps
das hier so hier ist es und hier ist es auch wenn man zwei aufmacht ist es laggy wenn man
zwei aufmacht ist es laggy ok dann machen wir den hier zu jetzt sollte es nicht mehr laggy sein
jetzt ist es immer noch laggy warum ist es immer noch laggy im ging es doch reload reload geht
immer hallo wow also es wird ja immer laggy mehr laggy naja flüssig ist was anderes flüssig
jetzt gehts jetzt gehts aber es laggt ich habe jetzt hier eine verzögung drin die hatte ich
vorher nicht jetzt ist die verzögung weg jetzt alles gut easy hat sich erledigt ok hier ja ok
darf man noch daumen hoch machen weil ich meine hier ok symbol darf man nicht mehr machen das ist
ganz ganz nein nein das ist direkt monka toss also hier verschieben wir das ganze mal so hallo hallo
geht das jetzt ja wunderbar jetzt flüssig alles da was ich jetzt ausprobieren muss ist folgendes
kann ich das overlayen das wäre natürlich richtig poggers wenn ich das wenn ich das overlayen
könnte dass man jetzt hier zum beispiel so sagt zack sticky poggers guckts euch an halt controls
nice hallo geht sehr schön da kann ich nämlich jetzt hier was machen und ihr könnt sehen und wenn
ich euch groß machen will dann mache ich einfach f bäm poggers so ist das gut alles da jetzt zeige
ich euch ach so die auflösung müsste 1080p sein ist die die auflösung ist ziemlich gut erkennt
ihr dass da wago drauf steht ich bin jetzt ungefähr meter vom bildschirm weg ich erkenne
set richtig da steht wago drauf erkennt ihr das kleine da hier war wago kann man das lesen kabelt
rüber ist kein kabel drüber ich bin meter weg ich sehe sich richtig jetzt mal hin ja kann man lesen
wunderbar dann ist es 1080p wenn man das klein kleinscheiß lesen kann gut ich zeige euch jetzt
mal was wir zum flaschen haben ich muss aber vorher kurz was trinken und jetzt kann ich
ganz wieder klein machen jetzt ist doch massive set up hier richtig nice also small small access
point hier auf small access point habe ich hier am start dafür da kann man dann flaschen mit dem
raspberry pi eben am access point anmelden und dann kann ich euch auch zeigen wie das wie das
ganze funktioniert das ist eigentlich ganz nice so jetzt zeige ich aber erst mal was wir haben
dass man mal hochs richtig hochziehen also ich bin der naggisch oder so aber die host ist irgendwie
beim rum hüpfen gerade gerutscht exquisite so ihr wollt das alles nicht sehen glaubt mir gut
dass die kamera nur da ist also was haben wir jetzt hier am start was haben wir hier am start
muss man den stuhl weg machen zu hause allein hose an btf warum nicht warum keine hose an wer
rennt ohne host daheim rum mit der kombi kannst auch kochstrüms machen ich ich esse lieber alleine so
ist immer noch dreckig hier guck mal gut das ding das das zieht halt auch fett irgendwie an
pepo fett hose an cringe bruder mann schienerzeug flaschen also ich zeige euch was wir haben wir haben
wir haben wo ist es denn hier also headset kabel hoffentlich reicht das headset kabel
wann wann jahres linux des tops nächstes jahr immer nächstes jahr so das ist das falsche
ist auch das falsche hier also gucken dass da kein name von mir drauf steht oder so wir haben
einmal gosund steckdosen 1 2 3 kabel gehäuse wegschmeißen gosund schiener chinesen kram
kommt das motor drauf wenn wir folgendermaßen machen flaschen über den raspberry pi dann
nehmen wir den small cute access point und da kann ich euch zeigen wie das was steht
da hinten drauf ach so meck und so geduldens ja who cares die fold passwort steht ist egal
habe ich eh geändert genau da werden wir das dann hier drüber anmelden und da kann ich euch
auch zeigen wo man wo man was sieht und vielleicht vielleicht hole ich noch ein zweites tablet
gleich ich habe doch hier noch irgendwo eins genau ich habe doch hier noch mein mein billig
50 euro amazon amazon fire hd8 das können wir verwenden klar also die werden geflasht
die werden geflasht immer hier made in china aber was witzig ist made in china aber oben drüber in
pro robert blietz blaskowitz ne bledowski rybnik pauland das ist quasi eine china chinesen polen
korporation cross joint joint steckdose also gekommen ist unter sich sozusagen und und meint
ihr das ist echt meint ihr das ist echt über dann nicht so sicher meint ihr das z-zeichen
ist echt kommt da das das motor drauf ja genau genau joint venture polen chinesen ja so also
die haben wir drei stück ich hätte mein bastler krams da hinten mal weg machen soll also 1 2 3
3 so die da und jetzt habe ich noch wer ist das ist das erste was wir jetzt machen heute
ich habe noch was anderes und zwar habe noch eine aber die werden wir nicht flaschen können aber
die habe ich mir auf andere an das chats gekauft eine tp link kamera habe ich mir geholt einfach
nur mal so angemerkt nicht wirklich dass man es irgendwie jetzt heute bräuchte hat kam er
chat hat gemeint die hat genau das was ich brauche da habe ich noch so meine zweifel
schmeißen wir mal kurz in die eck so und jetzt kommt ich habe es ich habe es wieder übertrieben
zack also wir haben uns jetzt mal kurz hier aus dem weg machen ach so welche kategorie
sollen wir eigentlich nehmen auf twitch soll man just chatting nehmen soll man diese neue
bastel bastel und und programmier kategorie nehmen oder nehmen wir science and technology
ich glaube wir bleiben bei just chatting ist glaube ich ist glaube ich sinnvoller technology
naja so wirklich ich glaube wir bleiben bei just chatting ich glaube wir bleiben bei just
just chatting aua ey die katz hat mich wieder gekratzt hier guckt euch dann es sieht ohne
scheiß hier ihr müsst euch mal guckt mal an wer mit meiner katz spielt ne seht ihr das
ne hier auf dem armen sieht man es guckt euch mal an sieht aus als hätte ich irgendwie als
ich irgendwie mehrere transportversuche hinter mir oder sowas aber das alles von der katz
die ist immer ein wenig aggressive wenn man mit ihr spielt hot tube beste kategorie dafür
also was ich am start habe ist folgendes eins zwei drei vier zack fünf sechs ich muss
in die kiste so sieben acht neun zehn warum macht keinen sinn aber es gab es in china
für drei euro 50 da habe ich mir gedacht warum warum nicht einfach zehn stück bestellen
ne es gab auch einer packs eins von den dinge hatten wir schon mal geflasht ja hatten wir
wir hatten auch wir haben auch schon mal das motor geflasht also an sich ist das nix wahnsinnig
neues haben wir schon mal gemacht ja so also damit damit fangen wir an haben brauchen
ja denke ich mir auch also damit fangen wir an als erstes müssen wir aber den raspberry
pie noch mal flaschen weil hier ist irgendein bastel hier ist irgendein bastel zeug von
mir drauf wo ich keine ahnung habe ob da irgendwas drauf ist was ich nicht zeigen will deswegen
mache ich mal übrigens diese micro sd karten zeige ich dir mal ein bisschen groß bisschen
größer die kann ich allen raspberry pie basteln empfehlen das ist samsung 64g pro endurance
ob es jetzt 32 64 oder 128 sind es eigentlich vollkommen egal aber pro endurance die haben
das ist quasi weil ich jetzt kann sein dass es mist hallo please focus kann auch sein
dass dass ich mist erzähle aber das ist glaube ich ein bisschen mehr richtung ssd chips was
da drinne ist als bei normalen sd karten die sind doch ziemlich endurance da geht das ding
nicht einfach kaputt sind das temperatursensor oder was sind das für dinge also das da sind
ich packe es mal aus ich packe mal ein aus das da sind temperatur luftfeuchtigkeit sensoren
ziemlich kleine ungefähr so groß wie der cute access point wir können ja mal kurz
größten vergleich machen ich packe mal aus also auspacken bei mir ist hier ungefähr
so aus das war jetzt bescheuert aber und weg in müll in müll so packen wir aus guckt
hier oh das darf ich nicht in die müll schmeißen mist ich habe sie müll geschmissen zack
da brauche ich noch da ist ja noch der aufkleber dabei da ist ja noch der aufkleber dabei
normalerweise ist da noch ein aufkleber dabei ich fürchte ich habe den aufkleber gerade
in müll geschmissen das war ziemlich low rq hier ich habe noch da ist er da ist er
also das kann ich wieder wegschmeißen hier aufkleber also das hier da ist da ist eine
batterie drin die kann man auch tauschen nicht so wie manche andere geräte wo du dann richtig
auf kriegst und hier ist halt so ein kleber um es an die wand zu machen ich habe bei mir
selbst im bad schon ein und das hält wirklich gut aber nur mit customfirmen die dinger sind
nur mit customfirmen zu gebrauchen weil die originalfirmen die schickt glaube ich sag
jetzt einfach mal irgendwas ich bin mir nicht sicher die gleich face reveal wo ist er zack
zack ah mist geht nicht die schicken alle 15 sekunden oder sowas die werte normalerweise
was halt total bescheuert ist warum willst du alle 15 sekunden die werte das das ding
ist normalerweise die batterie ist normalerweise durch da ist guck ob ich das aufkriege moment
es knackt es knackt eklig zu gucken ah jetzt das ist schlecht das geht nicht richtig auf
jetzt da ist so eine ganz kleine normale cr 2 0 hier cr 2032 drinne und das hält vielleicht
ein halbes drei monate bis ein halbes jahr in der original mit der originalfirmen mit
der customfirmen wir die wir drauf machen stellen wir ein dass das ding plus alle fünf
minuten schickt und ich habe das jetzt schon wann haben wir das im letzten stream uns angeguckt
das ist doch fast schon ein jahr her oder so und das ist jetzt bei 78 prozent batterie
also in dem fall muss man sagen die customfirmen hat richtig viele vorteile die hat mehr funktionen
die braucht keine china ab keine china cloud und nix und es hält länger also die dinger
würde ich niemals verwenden mit originalfirmen das wirklich so ein ding wo eigentlich alles
besser ist mit customfirmen heute mit handcam ja ich lasse es jetzt einfach mal auf und
wir flaschen jetzt mal ein ich mache die anderen grad mal weg ich bin mir nicht sicher ob
ich alle flasche heute ehrlich gesagt aber mal zwei drei werde ich auf jeden fall flaschen
so dann fangen wir mal an fangen wir mal mit dem raspberry pi an muss erstmal den raspberry
pi müssen wir ein aktuelles raspian drauf haben wobei es heißt ja gar nicht mehr raspian
es heißt ja raspberry pi os hat jemand eine ahnung warum die sich umbenannt haben es
doch wahrscheinlich stonks gründe oder irgendwelche marketing gründe was machen die die machen
im prinzip das was ihr vorne siehst temperatur und luft moment so temperatur temperatur
luftfeuchtigkeit das sieht dann auch genauso aus wie hier drauf das hat dann so ein happy
face und sad face wenn das gerät denkt dass es gut ist oder nicht ich stimme der sache
zum größten teil zu wenn es das anzeigt manchmal zeigt aber auch sprach sind an cute face wofür
braucht man das naja um zu wissen wie die luftfeuchtigkeit in die temperatur ist zum
beispiel im bad dass du weißt wie warm es ist im bad wie es die luftfeuchtigkeit im
bad eventuell willst du darauf dann reagieren und deine heizung anpassen deine heizung hoch
regeln deine heizung runter regeln vielleicht willst du sagen hey 15 minuten bevor ich duschen
gehe mache ich hoch bis auf was weiß ich so und so viel grad vielleicht willst du eine
warnung haben es ist warm du machst das fenster auf oder irgendwas in der richtung reichweite
ich würde mal sagen drei vier meter wenn es hoch kommt
bläst du die primär wegen des batterie laufzeit ja auch auch also primär also batterie laufzeit
auf jeden fall aber wofür der raspberry pi zum flaschen für also den raspberry pi brauchen
wir nicht unbedingt zum flaschen von denen die kann man auch mit jedem x beliebigen bluetooth
fähigen gerät flaschen aber wir machen zum raspberry pi den raspberry pi brauche ich
gleich zum tasmota flaschen von den von den china chinesen steckdosen ja so bin ich jetzt
grad stehen geblieben genau also wie gesagt ich vielleicht könnte man schon sagen primär
wegen der wegen der laufzeit aber auch dass ich keine china app keine china cloud brauche
und dass ich in mein heimautomatisierung einbinden kann das mit dem einbinden in die heimautomatisierung
kann ich euch heute nicht zeigen zumindest bei den dinger nicht weil da habe ich was
custom mäßiges am laufen aber die binden wir in unsere test in unsere test home assistant
installation ein ich habe es bei mir aktuell so gemacht ich habe ja auch so ein ding schon
im bad ich habe in meinem bad ein esp 32 hängen hinterm klo mit einem wasserdichten gehäuse
und der macht quasi bluetooth zu wlan relay nennen wir es mal also der scannt alle 20
sekunden die umgebung nach bluetooth geräten ob es neue gibt und dann lauscht er auf bluetooth
ob die geräte neue updates schicken wenn die geräte neue updates schicken dann schickt
er das über wlan an mein home assistant das haben wir glaube ich auch mal teilweise im
stream programmiert das ding so und der esp den ich im bad hängen habe der macht aktuell
für meine bluetooth waage für hier diese sensoren für die mi floras ich glaube ich
habe hier einen mi floras genau für die mi floras das ist das ist auch sensor bodenfeuchtigkeit
bodenfeuchtigkeit temperatur lichteinfall und ich glaube nährstoffe im boden oder sowas
ist eigentlich nur zum pflanzen überwachen gedacht davon habe ich auch zum pflanzen überwachen
aber ich habe da auch einen kühlschrank liegen das ist der optimale sensor ob man vergessen
hat den kühlschrank zuzumachen weil du hast hier einmal oben den sensor für lichteinfall
und ein temperatursensor das heißt du wirst auf jeden fall merken wenn du vergessen hast
den kühlschrank zuzumachen so und das macht der esp in meinem bad empfängt diese ganzen
sachen und meine bluetooth waage natürlich auch weil ich muss ja kontrollieren wie es
hier aussieht kann ich dann grafana graf machen was macht die akkulaufzeit von flora im kühlschrank
die ist glaube ich auch noch 75 prozent mach doch ein video zu deinem ganzen iot system
ja das plane ich schon die ganze zeit das problem ist ich kann das nicht so einfach
finde ich muss gucken dass ich nicht gar so viel leake dabei deswegen muss ich ein bisschen
überlegen ok wir fangen damit jetzt an wenn es mit dem raspberry pi nicht richtig funktioniert
dann flashe ich das eben mit meinem desktop wird auch funktionieren so auf gehts wir
werden jetzt erstmal den raspberry pi ein neues betriebssystem drauf machen wo habe
ich die sd karte hier da vorgas was hast du denn für eine waage irgendeine schaumy
me scale hoch ich habe eine schaumy me scale 2 glaube ich als waage die ist ja sowas hier
in der richtung nee meine sieht ein bisschen an aber sowas in der richtung ist es nee
20 euro ist aber relativ günstig die ist nicht flashbar macht aber nix in dem fall
du musst sie nicht perren die schickt über bluetooth auch ohne china cloud sachen raus
habe ich vielleicht noch die einser nee die einser oder habe ich schon die dreier ja hier
mit der anzeige um die habe ich belastbar bis 150 kilo oh close call nee ganz so schlimm
ist das nicht ja und die schickt auch über bluetooth dann die werte raus und die greife
ich dann auch ab mit dem esp der da steht so flaschen wir erstmal den raspberry pi also
wie gesagt die waage ist nicht flashbar wobei wir können eigentlich da ich hasse das ding
kennt ihr das auch kennt ihr dieses dieses rein ploppen wenn ihr zu schnell eint und
dann das ist ultra nervig das regt mich total auf
oh mist ich sehe ich sehe meine bedienelemente gerade für den browser nicht nicht so gut
platziert hier oben normalerweise braucht man es hier oben recht in der ecke nicht also
laden wir den kram mal runter raspberry pi os mit desktop nein raspberry pi os light
jepp safe ok während der runterlädt machen wir mal den kartenleser dran kartenleser alter
was ist das für musik ist es wie im dschungel hat er das erkannt tencent ja wohl hat er
erkannt wie heißt denn die smart home sache die du dir bestellt hast du meinst die geräte
also das war ich eine gezeigt habe sind große steckdosen da kann ich dir aber die genauen
die genaue bezeichnung wobei warte mal doch kann ich kann euch die genaue bezeichnung
zeigen ich habe nämlich ich habe doch nur in die ecke geschmissen die die packung hier
hier seck ja da steht leider nicht viel drauf da steht leider nicht viel drauf gosund führend
beim smart steckdose also wenn ihr auch führend beim smart steckdose sein wollt dann gosund
übrigens leute chalk des jahrhunderts es gibt jetzt keine gosund steckdosen mehr wisst
ihr auch warum weil korona vorbei ist und die heißen jetzt gesund tut schwitz ist so
schlecht all das ist so schlecht das schlechteste wird es allerzeit richtig feinst ja wie heißen
die dinger denn keine ahnung gosund vier stück smart steckdose ohne steht nichts drauf
ne besteht nichts drauf hier ist ein qr code westgenmark hier da ganz ganz wichtig schenzen
gosund technology co-limited nummer 14 diffo road gushu community xixiangstreet bau an district
schenzen support email ja das bestimmt sehr sehr ach komm mal da hier oben ist ein produkt
nummer das doch ganz sinnvoll hier gosund smart steckdose 16a 3680w pira made in china
also wenn man danach sucht wird man wahrscheinlich tasmotormäßig was finden was hast du für
die vier bezahlt ich weiß nicht mehr die habe ich über amazon gekauft und ist schon
ein bisschen her die lange die ganze zeit rum keine ahnung aliexpress habe ich die gekauft
deswegen weiß ich noch dass sie irgendwie nicht dass sie 350 oder so gekostet haben
so also das peripay download zackzack cd download wie siehts aus was peripay os booster etcher
wisst ihr eigentlich woran man merkt dass beim jahr 2021 lebt wenn man zum flaschen einer
sd karte einen browser startet das hier ist ja ein browser da weiß man die zukunft ist
jetzt aber die gibt es tatsächlich nicht oder ich finde zumindest die modelle sp1 sp1
nicht wir können nachher wir können gleich mal bei amazon gucken flash from file downloads
wo ist es denn ach da ist es doch ich habe es bloß nicht gesehen blind fps boomer augen
das zip direkt flaschen ja das kann das ding das entpackt das und flashs dann so select
target show hidden wow nein nein nein mein system drive will ich nicht flaschen hat
er das nicht erkannt hat er meine sd karte nicht erkannt zack warum hat er die sd karte
nicht erkannt ich habe es gar nicht doch doch warum er kennt er meine meine sd karte nicht
ich habe noch mehr keine sorge also an sd karten wird es nicht liegen da ist es doch
hier etcher enter file raspberry pi na gut ich habe update gemacht ich reboote mal ich
reboote mal man weiß ja nie bestimmt bestimmt den bing kernel update schauen wir mal so
mal den link zum browser rosa hol mal please die katze wie doch schon da rosa und viele
andere china brands wurden bei amazon rausgekickt warum wieso die dinger sind doch ok warum
ist das die startseite alter warum ist das einfach meine startseite warum habe ich das
als startseite mann das ist so fehl ja also gehts jetzt wieder ja wunderbar du ja ok down
und läuft so mal schauen ob es jetzt funktioniert etcher und ich darf ich jetzt flaschen flasch
vom feil jawoll select da ist es doch 64 g micro sd select flash bäm wunderbar eher
pie play mittlerweile gibt es sogar schon werbung im flascher glaubst nicht bei aliexpress hast
du die gefunden gucken wir mal aliexpress wir suchen die jetzt einfach mal nein nein
block geh weg ich will nicht ich will gar nicht wissen was ich da sehe bei aliexpress
wieder ok gosund 16a 38w oder wie hieß das zeug nee usb kann ich noch suchen sp wie heißt
die der chat weiß der chat weiß besser was ich hab als ich selbst hier guck mal das sind
die doch tatsächlich aber viel zu teuer bis zu 77 euro hat der ach hier vier stück das
ist viel zu teuer mann viel viel viel zu teuer ich hab das für glaub 25 30 euro bei amazon
gekauft es ist viel zu teuer was sind 56 euro gerade 2 euro oder 65 dollar oder macht auch
noch mal viel zu teuer leute viel zu teuer die china chinesen sind viel zu teuer gerade
wir gucken wir gucken wir gucken mal bei bengut bengut gosund block block alles blocken gosund
so flaschen ist komplett das ist viel zu teuer was ist denn mit den eine steckdose sieben
und zwar was ist denn los mit den china chinesen kann auch gar nicht sein ja die preise sind
schon ein bisschen besser aber auch nicht das was ich bezahlt habe die sehen übrigens
genauso aus wie meine hier haben die auch usb zweimal unten usb aber die frage ist halt
ob die flash flashbar sind schwer zu sagen also aktuell lohnt sich das überhaupt nicht
zu kaufen wie es aussieht gar nicht gar nicht also ein vierer pack für 25 euro das hat
sich gelohnt aber so so gar nicht so also mount st was sind das was haben wir hier stb sind
wir stb mount stb mount zack nein falsch unmount mount stb mount touch ssh ich weiß gar nicht
ob man das überhaupt noch braucht keine ahnung ob man noch ssh datei touchen muss beim raspberry
pie so und jetzt gucken wir ob der raspberry pie funktioniert schauen wir mal height controls
gucken wir mal ob der raspberry pie tut also wlan credentials für den raspberry pie brauche
ich nicht denn das wlan ist ja für das flashen gleich also das wlan brauchen wir nicht
was sind die ecke pfeffern hier gut dann wollen wir mal da micro sd rein stecken in die hintertür
usb kabel mir fällt da grad was auf das ist ein micro usb und das ist ein raspberry pie
hier ich hab da doch was wusste ich doch ich hab doch mittlerweile es hat sich mal wieder
gelohnt dass ich den 50er pack china usb kabel bestellt hab guckt ich hab mir den 50er pack
china usb kabel bestellt jetzt hab ich immer usb kabel und das ist micro usb auf usb c
poggers kombi da hat man alles hat man für alle einsätze hat man was dabei gut stecken
wir mal hier rein und wenn jetzt alles funktioniert ich sollte schon mal den netzwerkstecker ran
machen und wenn jetzt alles funktioniert dann hallo stecker geh mal rein dann sollte man
auch sehen hat man was gesehen ist es angegangen ja es anguckt seht ihr so funst zack so jetzt
muss ich mal ganz schnell auf mein dhcp server gehen und gucken was das ding kriegt was wird
das denn chat wir flaschen china steckdosen die die du oben links siehst und ein paar
thermostate die thermostate siehst du oben über dem raspberry pie
ip dhcp server leases raspberry pie 60 die musik wieder
der raspberry pie holt sich keine ip ha jetzt der hat ein bisschen gebraucht
die musik die macht mich ja fertig ok also ip ist am start gehen wir mal hierhin zack
net browser btf by the way das hier muss man auch sticky machen dass man es auch sieht
also ssh pie add enter yes so raspberry pie das erste was man macht wenn man sich auf
raspberry pie verbindet ne ist es nur raspberry ne so das erste was man macht wenn man sich
auf raspberry pie verbindet nicht passwd passwd ist für noobs das erste was man macht ist
ssh copy id weil ab dann kann man sich ohne passport einloggen und danach lässt man einfach
das default password weil security ist egal nein du kannst danach schon passwd machen
das wäre tatsächlich ganz sinnvoll oder aber in die ssh konfig gehen und direkt disablen
dass man login mit passport machen kann etc ssh sshd konf da kann ich mir auch wie kein
wim installiert zack das muss man gleich mal schnell ändern ok erstmal das wichtigste
nach installieren oder root passwd oder oder root user auf no login setzen oder was auch
immer gibt es zig varianten von so update ich lasse jetzt die default passwd update
nano nein nein nein kein nano chat kurze kurze kurze umfrage falls ein mod da ist ich mich
würde mal interessieren wim vi oder nano so die puristen unter uns upgrade emacs nein
das frage ich das gar nicht mal emacs ist eigentlich in der heutigen zeit ehrlich gesagt
nicht mehr wirklich relevant die ganze erweiterbarkeit von emacs wurde komplett überholt obsolet
quasi fast schon bisschen gemacht durch studio code welche editor ok zeig mal her nano oder
die nano erst sind am start hier die musik geht mir auf den keks ist eh gleich fertig
oh hier ist einer der markt die klassiker generell grafische editor ist immer bloat
nur awk und zet was anderes braucht man nicht also ich würde sagen nano gewinnt aber wim
ist mit dabei da sieht man halt dass nano doch der einsteigerfreundlichere editor ist
aber insgesamt mich nervt nano ich weiß beispielsweise immer nicht ich kann mir nicht merken wie
ich nano speichere ich glaube es kontrol x vielleicht so auch android handys wir haben
glaube ich war meine mir haben glaube ich gewonnen nvidia tablet geflasht im stream
ich erinnere mich noch dunkel aber selten kommt nicht so oft vor hand lieg finger lieg
darf der erst mal updaten und jetzt zeige ich euch nochmal was cooles also die sache
ist jetzt ja die um das hier zu updaten also ziel ist jetzt hier den da den da zu updaten
ups hier den da um den zu updaten mit customfirma muss man ein paar bluetooth dran kommen das
heißt wir brauchen den browser und aktiviert das bluetooth auf den raspberry pi damit das
funktioniert müssen wir irgendwie hier rauf das habe ich schon ein paar mal gezeigt aber
ich finde es immer wieder interessant gerade für Leute die neu sind müssen wir hier drauf
einen browser laufen lassen aber die ausgabe muss hier auf dem bildschirm sein nicht auf
den raspberry pi da ist ja kein monitor dran das heißt wir müssen uns den chrome oder
den firefox vielleicht firefox oder chrome mal gucken weiter leiten hiervon das muss
ich performant sein aber wir müssen weiter leiten ruckel ein bisschen aber es geht schon
dass das das das wirklich also das iphone kompatibilität browser mäßig ist absoluter
pains champ edge please wir können es danach mal probieren wie es im edge ist haha mach
mir mal kostenlosen sky raspberry ich weiß gar nicht was achso meinst du mit smart card
oder sowas ne das musst du schon selbst machen ich weiß gar nicht ob das überhaupt funktioniert
ich weiß gar nicht ob es da möglichkeiten aktuell gibt aber ganz ehrlich sky im jahr
2021 wer braucht denn sowas paytv in 2021 boomer hey ich bin der boomer hier ihr nicht
und ich brauch das auch nicht warum nicht einfach x ldp und dann windows remote desktop
kann man auch machen kann man auch machen aber x vorwärts einfacher guck mal leute
anstatt sky zu gucken könnt ihr einfach auf youtube gehen um meine videos schauen ist
ganz einfach viel besser braucht ihr kein abo und könnt trotzdem sachen gucken die
euch interessieren und wenn euch das ganz alles ganz besonders gut gefällt sowohl die
videos als auch die streams und ihr feststellt ich würde den max gerne unterstützen dann
gibt es jetzt die gute nachricht das geht ihr könnt mir einfach auch ein prime sub
geben mit dem prime sub kann man nämlich einen streamer seiner wahl einmal monatlich kostenlos
unterstützen das kostet nix zusätzlich schon gemacht ja die abo falle hat zugeschnappt
bei dir keine chancen beim immer korn dankeschön für den sub die abo falle klappt immer wieder
ich bin begeistert porras abo falle mister dolphin danke für den sub alles first time
subscriber ihr habt damit einen holzkeks bekommen obi xd wenn ihr jetzt im chat schreibt die
gerade gesagt haben ihr habt jetzt ein sub badge ihr habt jetzt den keks den keks in
holz für den ersten monat im zweiten monat den keks im original und ab dem dritten monat
den keks in silber oder so glaube ich und dann den keks in diamant und dann den keks
in gold mit halskette so muss das sein und danach gibt es auch nichts neues phoenix dankeschön
für den sub very effektiv ja die abo falle wer ist einmal ich hab roffel gelesen krieg
rollo wl rollo wl dankeschön für den sub drei monate du hast jetzt den keks in silber
glaube ich mit drei monaten so haben wir jetzt geupdatet exzellent also wir installieren
jetzt mal ein chrome wie heißt denn das hier eigentlich chromium browser ich hoffe das
installiert jetzt kein snap wenn die jetzt diesen ubuntu krempel machen mit snap dann
dann raste ich aus dann raste ich aus man ne also hoffentlich kein snap bitte bitte
kein snap ne sieht nicht nach snap aus alles gut mocha weh einfach firefox ja wir müssen
mal gucken mit was es geht was ist denn mit snap falsch zum beispiel wenn du jetzt zugriff
auf bluetooth sachen brauchst dann geht es nicht richtig also snap ist pains champ aber
so ist besser ich stimme zu was der chat sagt der chat sagt anus würde ich ähnlich sehen
ja es gibt chromium und chromium browser es ist wahrscheinlich einfach nur irgendein
meta package davon wenn ich chromium browser installiere installiert er wahrscheinlich
auch noch schriftarten und alles mit das ist irgendein meta package hier oben sieht
man es ja der installiert der installiert halb x und font libraries und gedöns mit
gut das brauchst du für ein browser aber auch so und wenn wir jetzt den chrome installiert
haben dann müssen wir jetzt mal auf github und schauen wie das hier nochmal genau war
github weil ich weiß gar nicht mehr wie das genau ging hier die firmware brauchen wir
zuletzt aktualisiert vor 11 tagen also hier für den da ne für die kleine den kleinen
scheißer hier also wie ging das nochmal mit dem flaschen ja genauso sieht es dann aus
it's possible to update firmware auf web tool dahin müssen wir ok und das müssen wir
in raspberry pi ausführen alles klar oah herr gith statt shithub gesagt height unknown
probieren wir mal was immer das macht nicht dass ich hier noch die bluetooth geräte vom
nachbar liege oder so ja richtig big brain ui ist das hier also wo sind wir hier das
dauert noch muss man installieren gut da machen nämlich zuerst einmal drei stück davon wenn
wir einen haben ist das andere ja einfach einfach schnell gemacht und dann machen wir die steckdosen
hier dann machen wir die steckdosen selbst so umliegen dann machen wir steckdosen weil
für die steckdosen müssen wir auf raspberry pi ein bisschen mehr installieren und hoffen
dass das mit tuja convert alles funktioniert aber müsste eigentlich gehen ich habe es
ja schon mal ausprobiert also jetzt haben wir alles drauf gucken wir mal x forwarding chrome
schrummium browser da ist er so und ihr denkt euch jetzt was ist daran so besonders das ist
doch einfach nur ein chrome nein das ist nicht einfach nur ein chrome das hier ihr seht schon
wie das laggt das hier ist ein chrome also die ausgabe die grafische ausgabe von dem
chrome läuft also der chrome läuft auf dem raspberry pi aber ich sehe ihn hier bei mir
auf dem desktop das ist poggers x forwarding man kann das ganze übrigens noch mal so als
tipp wenn euch x forwarding zu langsam ist und ihr das vielleicht ein bisschen langsamer
internet connection macht minus c dann komprimiert er die bilder auch und es ist noch ein ticken
schneller aber lokal macht es eigentlich keinen großen unterschied ich meine performance
haben wir hier youtube macht also performance ihr seht schon also performance sachen werdet
ihr hier nicht nicht irgendwie gewinnen aber das braucht ihr zum flaschen auch gar nicht
was ist dann für das für ein reagentsklasse im chrome ganz oben was das da das da experiments
ist sehr interessant ist schön dass dir jetzt gefällt das freut mich ich mache die kompression
wieder aus ich habe das kühl das macht in dem fall sogar langsamer gut also dann flaschen
wir mal gucken ob das ganze funktioniert zack um halt anderen alles klar mal gucken ob das
jetzt geht ich habe schon eine weile nicht mehr gemacht connect nope normalerweise müsste
jetzt abfrage kommen musste man das nicht noch einschalten warum musste man das nicht
noch einschalten ging das vielleicht mit ging das vielleicht mit moment can i use web bluetooth
welchem browser geht das can i use web bluetooth es geht in chrome geht es in firefox geht
es gar nicht in chrome geht es in edge geht es jebaited in edge dann geht es wahrscheinlich
auch in chrome wo ist denn chrome hier chrome sollte eigentlich gehen warum funktioniert
das nicht muss ich experiments vielleicht einmal romium web bluetooth warum geht das nicht
was passiert wenn ich das hier lokal mache wie sieht das lokal aus connect ach geht auch
nicht ok so wenn ich was was ist wenn ich den chrome bei mir hier mache da gerade geöffnet
wahrscheinlich ist es verbugged ok kann es sein dass der chrome das nicht kann das wäre
natürlich ein ein sehr großer pains pains champsierung firefox kann es anscheinend erst
recht nicht das ist ja fail wie mache ich denn das jetzt ich habe hier doch kein bluetooth
am rechner beziehungsweise ich habe nur nicht mal eine antenne dran ok das ist fail bluetooth
ist undefined was kommt hier als fehlermeldung das ist natürlich dumm
request device of undefined ja gut dann machen wir es im desktop mal gucken ob das funktioniert
hier chrome guck mal mal also ich muss mir erst einmal die anleitung durchlesen wie das
jetzt funktioniert also wie was was muss man machen also autoflash custom firmen wir down
our latest bin file latest release and open the web flasher connect thermostat der thermos
mit latest release soll ich runterladen ok latest release wir versuchen es mal mein desktop
das problem an meinem desktop ist ich habe zwar bluetooth aber ich habe keine antennen
und nix angeschlossen mal gucken ob das funktioniert hast du als root gestartet meinst du da dran
liegt das glaube ich nicht der mag nicht als root starten also wrong authentifizier nee
ich glaube das liegt daran weil es chrome ist ne ne das liegt nicht ja gut erstes laden
was hier unter also thermometer bin in zweifels fall lege ich das einfach auf den rechner
drauf und dann sein sollte die reichweite ausreichen ok flasher height unknown jawoll
wir müssen ja nicht den nachbar liegen hier connect bluetooth aktivieren achso moment
ging das nicht hier drüber ich verwende dieses menu nie wow was das repair drive errors
monkaS monkaS smoke bluetooth ja bluetooth poggers on ok connect shield trim screen was
ist ar ok also es scheint zu funktionieren dann lade ich mir jetzt hier mal das aktuelle
release runter habe ich schon also was wir jetzt mal machen ist folgendes haben wir hier
mal fullscreen ich werde jetzt mal hier hinten die batterie rausziehen und wir lassen das
laufen ok zack ich ziehe die batterie raus plopp es geht an guckt hier es geht an poggers
und jetzt ist abgebrochen ich muss ich muss es ein bisschen näher an meinen rechner dran
legen glaube ich das ist echt kacke ich habe keine antennen dran ich habe keine ich habe
keine antennen an meinem an an meinem mainboard
come on scan ich musste antenne suchen um das da hinten dran zu machen mir lasst es einfach
mal kurz laufen sind die antennen nicht für wlan nee ich glaube die sind für beides
du musst auf dem raspberry pi das land einstellen dann geht bluetooth ernsthaft?
zack testen wir jetzt testen wir jetzt wenn der chat das sagt dann stimmt das der chat
kennt sich aus ich muss das land einstellen auf dem raspberry pi das heißt ich muss machen
beconfig localization options muss ich wlan country einstellen wahrscheinlich wlan country
wo ist germany wo ist germany what the fuck oh stimmt doch ok und dann muss ich noch was
muss ich noch was einstellen beidstreichs weißt du das hier der rest kann es ja nicht
sein timezone timezone europe europe berlin sollte gehen rebooten mal yes immer rebooten
london made oi aber es ist schonmal ihr seht das da das scheint prinzipiell zu funktionieren
sonst wird da nicht 24,1 grad stehen 24,1 grad rein 850 grad luftfeuchtigkeit hoffentlich
sind wir wieder da haben die supermärkte in uk eigentlich wieder essen hab gehört die
haben da probleme no oh guck mal guck mal matching ok connect und nope nope funktioniert
nicht jebaited jebaited wie kann man das raspberry raspberry pi bluetooth web wir suchen einfach
mal aus web bluetooth hab ich irgendwas muss ich noch irgendwas anderes installieren blue
alza hört sich an wie bluetooth problem blue alza klingt mir nach einem sound für sound
dir fehlen die bluetooth reiber hast du probieren wir mal also ich zähle jetzt mal das was
der will das ist ja das ist ja sound gedöns das kann es ja schon mal nicht sein also hi
chromium web bluetooth ab install was braucht man da für alles bluts wie heißt das ding
heißt die blut blut blut blut blut blut blut blut blut blut blut blut blut blut blut
ab install bluts muss man raspberry konfig erst aktivieren stimmt raspberry konfig muss
man das erst aktuelle interfaces ne oder hi bluetooth activate das hab ich alles mach
ich so selten bluetooth verbinden läuft der bluetooth service können wir gucken hi bluetooth
ist neuestes status running ne der sap driver monka ist was was will sap auf meinem bluetooth
auf meinem raspberry pie bluetooth management ok also es ist eigentlich alles drauf was man
braucht schnell weg ja es ist es ist eigentlich alles drauf was man braucht würde ich mal
sagen bluts blu das haben wir ja alles drauf alles alles drauf scheint alles zu funktionieren
ich mach das über meinen desktop das ist doch sinnlos aber ab genau so sinnlos funktioniert
einfach nicht das ist ja low brain connect bam cannot ok keine ahnung einziges was mir
einfällt ich kann mal hier nach raspberry pie suchen vielleicht hätte schon einer was
geschrieben raspberry pie connect flash data ok ich probiers jetzt vom desktop aus scheiß
drauf ne ne ne ne wir connect nicht wie gesagt ich will die geräte vom nachbarn nicht leaken
oder so ich leg das jetzt mal auf mein rechner ist er das nicht ist er das nicht koppeln
ist er das nicht das ist er doch das ist er doch oder das ist er doch 38,8 hat er angeblich
das ist er doch 59 jawoll das ist er das ist er das ist er wir sind gekoppelt ok so wie
gehts jetzt weiter äh hier wie gehts jetzt weiter webflasher works how to install download
releases connect her mit a search may take a while point after click to do activation
do do activation or token leaked umfg after the next is always be careful that the right
one is not project firma click on start flashing ok her moment was was soll ich machen was
soll ich machen while it's doing so you can only select the firmware file ok download ok
click on start flash ey das das ui ist richtig richtig wo wo wo steht hier start ah start
flash
scheint zu funktionieren scheint zu funktionieren
er ist nicht sonderlich schnell mit dem flaschen muss man mal sagen nur für echte hacker mans
hier heute wieder das ui ist fast so gut wie das von battlefiend
2042 ich erkenne gewisse parallelen ja übrigens leute wenn ich was im chat überlebe überlese
schreibt entwupplos davor und ich gehe auch nachher den chat noch mal durch aber es kann
sein dass ich nicht dass ich heute nicht mit bekomme update dann und jetzt
jetzt ist das update dann ich muss mal kurz gucken zeigt was an ja es zeigt was an
neu starten searching for devices disconnected ist es jetzt ok connected das jetzt neu
after flashing is done device should reboot if the screen stays off pull battery out to
flash stockfilmer back just open the corresponding filing ok connect ah muss ich jetzt wait a
minute ah der macht reconnect ne ne der macht ein reconnect detected custom firmware moment
er checkts er checkts grad schon und jetzt detected custom firmware weiter und jetzt
lost champ oh der ist ja jetzt connected oder nicht 24.0606 ne was hat denn der hier oben
jetzt zeigt jetzt hier an 24 58 hat das jetzt funktioniert oder nicht detected custom firmware
gibt's gibt's dazu ein video das haben wir das letzte mal schon angeguckt ich brauch
den flasher flasher ist das datenfernübertragung wahrscheinlich nicht ok
es ist es ist ein bisschen ein bisschen kryptisch aber ich glaube da ist jetzt connected ehrlich
gesagt ich glaube da ist connect smiley off so ich guck jetzt mal ob der wir gucken uns
das jetzt mal zusammen an ist der smiley jetzt off da ist nix off aber es ist custom firmware
geflasht ok connect wie gesagt ich will die nachbargeräte nicht unbedingt reveal ja nochmal
verbinden aber das flaschen hat schon mal funktioniert ich bin ich bin begeistert das
problem ist immer noch ich habe keine ich habe keine antenne ich habe keine antenne
an meinem rechner das ist ziemlich er paint's champ ich musste jetzt mal eine antenne dran
schrauben neben connect ist reconnect reconnect zu was soll er sich dann bitte schon reconnecten
da weißt du überhaupt nicht wohin ich glaube nicht dass das funktioniert connect bl e smart
das wird es nicht sein oder ich lasse es mal kurz laufen ich habe doch irgendwo eine antenne
ich muss meine antenne an mein rechner schrauben ich benutze das bluetooth normalerweise dort
nicht warte mal wo habe ich denn eine antenne ich habe bestimmt irgendwo eine antenne wo
könnte ich gerne haben
ich habe normalerweise auch selten antennen rumfliegen
ich habe eine gefunden leute antenne ist am start ich habe die antenne am rechner dran
noch mal suchen noch mal suchen excellent so gucken ob das jetzt funktioniert warum geht
das aus wenn ich weg switchen das ist ziemlich ziemlich er paint's champ so connect nein meine
güte ich will den nachbarn nicht liegen so gut das macht nichts wisst ihr was ich jetzt
mache ich mache jetzt einfach mal ich mache jetzt ich war jetzt batterie raus und batterie
rein was ist batterie was runter gefallen ok
leute ich habe es kaputt gemacht leute ich habe es gebrickt guckt mal schaut mal hier
ich habe die batterie raus gemacht und die batterie muss ja so rum rein hier so rum f
ich weiß nicht wie man das durch batterien raus machen zerstören kann ehrlich gesagt
oder ist sie oder ist sie falsch rum drin jetzt nee so muss das zur schwachsinn so muss
es so rum rein es ist dead nee das ist es nicht kriegst hier das ist sie hat die gehäuse
rückseite einen kontakt ist das hier nee das drückt es einfach nur rein ok ich hätte
nicht gedacht dass man mit dem entfernen von der batterie das ding pricken kann das ist
ziemlich selten ziemlich selten es kann auch nicht sein dass es kaputt ist glaube ich nicht
aber das ist richtig drin guckt es kann es nicht anders rein machen kann es nicht anders
rein machen ist es dead aber warum ist es dead ok wir machen es einfach mal zu ich glaube
wie rum wait a minute wie rum muss es so rum so rum sieht doch gut aus oder vielleicht doch
so rum so rum nee ok wie rum muss es denn müsstest du beim raspberry pi noch bluetooth in chrome
aktivieren das probieren wir mal aus gute frage kurz checken chrome gucken wir mal flex
nee was ist es chrome chrome flex alter jetzt komm an gib alles chrome blue use the new
permissions back and for web bluetooth default nee muss man anscheinend nicht aktivieren
ist schon ist schon aktiviert was soll ich machen ok ich mache das was der chat sagt
der chat hat bestimmt wieder recht also was soll ich mal chrome doppelpunkt flex slash
ok experimental web das da enables experimental web verpflichtung der leitende welle hat man
ok enable relaunch ich glaube immer noch nicht dass es kaputt ist kann es nicht sein ok und
jetzt machen wir das andere auf was wir schon auf hatten und gucken ob er flaschen kann
die battlefield beta nee nee nee nee nee nee nee nee nee nee nee nee nee nee nee
nee nee nee nee nee nee nee nee nee nee nee nee nee nee nee nee nee nee nee pollution
Ich das kaputt gemacht habe wie habe ich das denn bitteschön kaputt das kann doch nicht sein dass ich das wirklich kaputt gemacht
Hab damit ich packe jetzt noch, mal eins aus
Ich packe ich packe jetzt noch, mal eins aus und dann gucken wir uns das mal an kann doch nicht sein dass es kaputt geht vom
Einfachen batterien batterien raus machen also machen wir mal auf
Okay, ich muss jetzt erst mal gucken wie es aufgeht also wie das hier drauf ist
So, so geht es zu das heißt hier die Symbole müssen ja ich erkenne halt nicht was unten und was oben ist halt im ding
Die Symbole müssen unten da wo die Batterie zusammen geht okay das heißt so, so macht man es zu
Es ist dead
Dead af
Was ziemlich sagt kann doch nicht sein dass es verreckt ich glaube es immer nur nicht dass es verreckt
So achtung
Moment
Ist das display im arsch guckt mal man sieht da ein bisschen was
Guckt mal jetzt sieht man da was jetzt sieht man was und passt mal auf wenn ich die batterie raus mache
Ist weg
Wechseln mal die batterie
Wechseln mal die batterie okay das machen wir also das hier das hier mit dem ding vorne drauf ist broken
Muss das irgendwie markieren
Wie markiere ich das denn jetzt hier das ist broken das ist broken mit dem blauen und das das hier geht noch
Das hier geht noch
Okay, so also erst mal testen wenn ich das hier raus mache ob dann noch alles geht
Alter was welcher china chineser hat sich das wieder ausgedacht okay zack
Geht geht okay hier raus und der rein
Geht
Ich habe es gebrückt ich habe es irgendwie kaputt gemacht
Ich weiß nicht wie ich habe es irgendwie ich habe es zerstört break jam
Brick jam
Okay das gucke ich mir andermann
Oh
Weg weggesprüht hier dann flaschen wir den jetzt auch mal schnell
Flaschen wir den hier schnell connect
So wieder warten bis das erkennt
Wir sind da vielleicht noch per plutus aktiviert werden ja wahrscheinlich
Kann man in der custom firma den kontrast einstellen möglich nee glaube ich nicht das ist fix in dem display
Da ist er koppeln
Okay, connecting
Okay, connecting post champ
Nice
2550 ja das ist richtiger connectin du activation
Man sieht grad nichts ich guck mal ich leg den so hin dass man hier zugucken kann vielleicht
Ich weiß nicht ob der was ob der was anzeigt
So ist perfekt
Okay, denn ich dazu den nächsten pricks ja
Gibt es gibt es da verschiedene
Da gibt es da gibt es sogar nur. Hi da gibt es doch nur sogar nur eine firma zum download
Also wenn ich den nächsten prick dann weiß ich auf jeden fall dass es an der firma liegt
Aber in den downloads
Gibt es nur es es gibt nur diese eine firma
Ja, okay, also select firma das da
Gibt es eine checksumme könnte ich machen machen wir mal
Cd
Wo sind wir denn hier gelandet die downloads md5 sum atc
D
Thermometer bin
So checksumme checken
Please
Mein gott windows alter
Tja gibt keine checksumme dazu. Wir flashen es jetzt einfach noch mal neu. Datei auswählen
Connected you can now do activation. Habe ich gemacht start flashing beim
Ok gucken wir immer zu beim flaschen macht er beim flaschen irgendwas nope
Stand da prerelease. Oh, oh monka. Oh, das steht aber bei allem da steht bei allem prerelease da
Vergleich die checksumme dabei und hat 5 hat time vom chat wieder
Ich weiß schon ich weiß schon der chat der chat kennt sich einfach aus
zur atc
Was ist leerzeichen hier so bin ja ist es gleiche zweimal falsch da umgeladen wird es nicht haben
Um 60 prozenten dohne 55
Also erster erster ist schon
Dafür habe ich jetzt eine knopfzelle die kostet wahrscheinlich in deutschland mehr als das ganze gerät
Dann so er sollte sich jetzt rebooten reboot er sich jetzt
Was bringt die firmen wäre die batterie hält länger
Ist connected break jam
Sollte sich gleich reconnecten
Ich glaube ich weiß nicht ob man den reboot sieht ehrlich gesagt
Ich weiß nicht ob man den Reboot sieht, ich meine das ist so ein Display wo sich kaum
was verändert, das kann auch so dass man den Reboot nicht sieht, solange eine Batterie
drin ist.
Okay, reconnecte da jetzt.
He doesn't know.
Warum so warm bei dir?
Naja, Lampen an, zwei Rechner an, Türen zu, Halsung an, Detected Custom Firmware,
das ist ja eigentlich schon mal gut, da würde ich sagen der hat sich jetzt connected.
Do activation, not connected, jebaited alter, jebaited, connected custom firmware, not connected.
Reconnect.
Detected, reconnected, disconnected, jebaited, ich meine da müsste 25,5, das ist schon richtig
dass der 25,5 anzeigt, ey wenn das Ding jetzt wieder brickt ist, da krieg ich Anfälle.
Smiley off, Setting A0 was?
Send successfully?
Ne der Smiley ist nicht off.
Ich hab Angst das Ding neu zu starten Leute, wenn ich das Ding neu starte dann gehts bestimmt
wieder kaputt.
Brickt.
ATC gekoppelt, jawoll.
Connecting, sehr gut, auf connecte.
Detected Custom Firmware, not connected, was jebaited mich das Ding die ganze Zeit, mach
ich irgendwas falsch?
Ich kann nach Bluetooth, ne, scan hier nix.
Klick mal show battery, enable, was send successfully, ne, ne, ne, ne, detected, reconnected, disconnected,
du musst die settings vor dem flashen einstellen, nein, nein, muss ich nicht, ich hab das ja
schonmal gemacht, nein, nein, muss ich nicht, man konnte das hier so go on the fly einstellen,
man könnte hier z.B. sagen auch off oder, oder blinking oder so, das hat funktioniert.
To activation, how to flash or unprick the device, ne, ne, ne, ne.
Scan nach Bluetooth, reconnect, reconnected halt einfach nicht.
Detected Custom Firmware, das ist doch irgendwie jebaited, outdated, overrated, da stimmt doch
was nicht, Fahrenheit, jawoll gib mir, geht das hier noch, ist das Kamerabild noch da,
okay Leute, soll ich mal, soll ich, ich mach mal ein neues Tab auf kurz, ATC gekoppelt.
Sensor Offset, aber das war Detecting, der kann sich verbinden, Detecting Custom Firmware,
was macht der sonst nicht, Issues, GitHub Issues, genau, zeig her, cannot reconnect
after flashing Custom Firmware, ah ich bin ja auch dumm, ich hab das falsche geflashed,
das hier hätten wir flaschen müssen, also das geht beides, es geht beides, es geht beides,
das hier ist nur das ältere, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay,
okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
You can now do some settings, nope, okay ich kann jetzt das andere einfach flaschen oder,
ich kann jetzt das andere einfach flaschen, okay, over the air Flasher, also den hier
nehmen wir jetzt, if you are, Linux, Linux, ja das haben wir gemacht, das hat nicht, hat
nichts gebracht, das habe ich probiert, aber das ging nicht, Enabled, muss man bestimmt
neu starten danach, habe ich aber schon gemacht, so also nehmen wir mal den Flasher hier, vielleicht
geht der, vielleicht ist er besser, China Chinesen Flasher, ah, ah, Plutus Adapter not available,
okay, also connect, was ist wenn ich reconnect mache, reconnect wohin, man weiß es nicht,
connect, ATC, koppeln, ah, detected on use, mach ich, mach ich, detected on, oh ich soll
was anderes machen, okay, what, warum gibt es da, warum gibt es da, warum gibt es da
zwei verschiedene Dinger, ist das, ist das um die alte Firmware zu upgraden versus die
neue, oder was ist das jetzt, jetzt, jetzt wird es abgedreht, okay, okay, okay, okay,
okay, wisst ihr was, also ich bin connected, okay, connect, jawoll, koppeln, connected,
Datei auswählen, wir flashen jetzt das andere, download, releases, HTMLzip, wo sind die binaries,
wo sind die binaries dafür, Firmware binaries, hier, das da, das haben wir, 0.3 MMC, das
da, das da, ja, Firmware, 3.1, bam, okay, OTA, Datei auswählen, 3.1, start flash, okay,
okay, da flasht, Leute, das Ding, es lebt noch, es lebt noch, vielleicht ist es doch
nicht geprickt, not pricked, maybe not pricked, man sollte auch die richtige Firmware flashen,
welches von den beiden, eine Frage, wann zeigst du dich bei einer Million Abos auf
YouTube, das geht viel schneller als die original Firmware, Postchamp, den anderen kannst du
ansteigen per Flywire, was zum Teufel ist ein Flywire, okay, clear log, connect, gekoppelt,
das klingt gut, connecting to, ha, da sind wir, okay, der lebt, da sind wir, nice, okay,
jetzt kann man auch so Sachen einstellen wie smiley, den da, perfekt, send config, ändert
sich nichts, show clock on LCD, test, she baited, okay, repair LCD, mal gucken, mal gucken,
also, was kann man hier machen, get config, okay, abrufen und so geht immer noch, set
time, ich refresh nochmal, reconnect, gekoppelt, okay, nice, connecting, da sind wir, okay,
also die Verbindung funktioniert, welche Voraussetzungen brauche ich um die Thermo zu installieren könnte
man die uralte Heizung anbringen, du kannst die anheizung anbringen, aber dafür sind
sie nicht gedacht, die sind zum Beispiel um sie ins Bad zu hängen mit Luftfeuchtigkeit
so gedacht, also, jetzt müssen wir mal was testen, was, was, was können wir denn jetzt
hier machen, dass wir irgendwas sehen, also, was ich beispielsweise bei mir eingestellt
habe, dass das switcht, also bei mir im Bad, switcht das und hat noch ne Batterieanzeige
unten, Batterie, Batterieanzeige, Batterie, Hekchen, show, macht nichts, also das UI ist,
das UI ist pepega as fuck, wer hat sich dieses UI ausgedacht, ja set config habe ich schon
gemacht, ich glaube ich muss es neu starten Leute, ich glaube ich muss es neu starten,
ich glaube das ist kaputt, ah send battery, ne, get config, battery, send config, okay,
send config, hä, ich weiß gar nicht, ach hier, show bad, nicht das da, alter meine
Güte hier, wer hat sich das denn ausgedacht, okay, okay, get config, okay, das LCD ist
kaputt, das, ähm, ich starte jetzt neu, ich starte jetzt neu, okay Leute, wir brauchen
eine prediction, klappt der Reboot oder nicht, ich mach mal ne prediction, prediction, oma
in Vorhersage starten, ist klappt Reboot, ja, nein, oder überlebt es den Reboot, überlebt
es den Reboot, geht es nach dem Reboot, fragen wir so, Vorhersage starten, bam, oh 30 Sekunden
war vielleicht ein bisschen kurz, prediction max update, ne ganz anderes Gerät, tja, ich
müsste mal bei mir im Bad gucken, aber bei mir im Bad hätte er erkennen müssen, dass
die Batterie Anzeige und so drin ist, okay, was ist rausgekommen bei der prediction, hab
ich jetzt gar nicht gesehen, 50-50, ziemlich genau, 50-50 turbo, danke für den Sub, okay
Reboot, Reboot, oh, oh nee,
okay, das Testplan geht nicht an, ich hab noch 8 Stück, mal gucken, ob sich das verbindet,
mal gucken, ob sich das verbindet, reconnect, der geht, guckt mal, der geht noch, der ist
nicht prickt, das Display funktioniert bloß aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht, okay, ja
Leute ihr müsst mir nicht alles 5 mal schreiben, ich komm selbst auf die Idee da drauf zu
klicken, glaubt's mir, so, repair LCD, ne, mal, wie erkennt man das hier, erkennt man
Fullscreen, eben hatte ich es doch ganz gut hier, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm, hm,
hm, hm, hm, hm, das haben wir gut gemacht.
mach mal oben original firmware ob es dann wieder geht
select firmware custom firmware 3.2 oder original firmware ok wir machen wir machen
die original firmware drauf du hast ja 3.1 habe ich 3.1 tatsächlich dann mach ich nächstes
mal falls es gar nicht geht mach ich das nächste mal wieder über den flasher erstmal original
firmware drauf prediction resolve ja es funktioniert nicht wie ging das jetzt mit prediction auf
lösen prediction summary oder habt ihr schon gelöst habt ihr schon gelöst achso ich habe
mich schon gewundert warum kann ich das nicht machen ok 87 ne 82 87 90 prozent drone reboot
prager prager nop
batterie raus batterie rein shit
der Name hat sich jetzt geändert deswegen geht das mit reconnect nicht ok ich mache
jetzt die batterie raus und wieder rein
nein das ist brickt wir haben noch eins gut jetzt wisst ihr warum ich immer zehn stück
bestelle
schickt die kaputten zurück das kannst du bei aliexpress erst echt machen die würden
das sehr wahrscheinlich also ganz ehrlich aliexpress ist da ziemlich also alles was ich bisher hatte
mit den relativ zuvorkommend wenn ich sage 2 out of 10 brauchen dann kriege ich das kriege
ich sieben euro wieder bis gerade der stand einer stand ist zwei brickt
noch mal
ok bei der gelegenheit ich packe schon mal das nächste aus
wunderbar ok wenn ich nur zwei bricke ist auch ok ist in ordnung ist in ordnung meine
das ist ok macht es hier mal zu ich mach chrome neu auf und hier mache ich mal die batterie
raus ok heißt alles mit batterie raus ist brauchen ok
jetzt muss ich erstmal scannen ich habe auch schon eins ohne probleme geflasht
jetzt muss er es nur noch finden nope
falsch kein fernseher ich lege es mal ein bisschen näher an rechner
koppeln connecting to
reconnect ich will ausprobieren ob das funktioniert wenn ich so weit weglege ich habe das nämlich
absichtlich ein bisschen weggelegt vielleicht hat es übertragungsprobleme ne scheint zu
funktionieren ok du activation und jetzt mache ich ich mache es über das web interface über
das web interface wir machen keine prediction jetzt wir machen das jetzt einfach oh ne wir
haben schon eine prediction wird das der chat will es kaputt sehen ok custom firmware version
3.2 start flashing huge was ist für ein links predicted blue
come on
auf hoffentlich geht das jetzt also ich habe jetzt auf jeden fall die richtige wir haben
jetzt auf jeden fall die richtige firmware
präge haben wir nicht ein präge ppega ne haben wir nicht gibt es nicht präge als
emote präge präge das brauchen wir das muss aktivieren präge connect with switch ja autorisieren
ich habe es geedet add to my channel präge ob es jetzt funktioniert ja es funktioniert
präge boos mit großem p bessere version das ist mit animation wir lassen es mal ohne animation
ok hat er jetzt geflasht hat er jetzt geflasht ok anscheinend jetzt reconnect ok das geht
schon mal das geht schon mal also show battery send config
waiting notify for notify for data get config
stamp scala ändern du meinst hier von erfahrenheit
reconnect aufs practice sehen wir gleich
was ist denn da kaputt ich habe das letzte mal auch ohne probleme habe ich das geflasht
ich habe jetzt das richtige ok unabhängig davon ob das koppeln und so geht wir restarten
jetzt aber das geht so kacke auf der kram
alter
ripp ich gucke jetzt mal in die github issues das display geht übrigens also es ist nur
mega dunkel also gehen ist ein bisschen an habe ich die falsche revision oder sowas
habe ich irgendwie inkompatible china chinesen version
also was habe ich denn hier guckt mal ich habe da stehts guckt mal lywsd03mmc das klingt
auch gut schaun wir mal falsche falsche seite
wait a minute wünsche jetzt hier ja das da
moment ich muss auf die richtige seite hier ja das habe ich lywsd03mmc genau das habe
ich guckt genau das richtige ist es ja
lywsd03mmc tja aber wenn die dinger so einfach kaputt gehen
ist ziemlich ziemlich sackig hat er sich jetzt eigentlich reconnected hier
Leute weißt ihr wisst ihr was ich mache ich lasse mal kurz die batterie einfach kurz raus
1 2 3 4 5 6 und pusten pusten hilft immer bam und es funktioniert nicht funktioniert
jetzt erkennt das ja irgendwie gar nicht mehr die andere war wenigstens noch erreichbar
oder es braucht einfach ein bisschen also ich werde es jetzt sein lassen die anderen
die anderen mache ich jetzt nicht auch noch wie viele funktionierende brauchst du am besten
die restlichen 7 hast du kein laptop nicht dass es beim übertragen abricht der sagt
ja ist 100% und der kommt ja auch danach hoch der kommt ja auch danach hoch und funktioniert
haben wir hier mal zu
schon mal an und aus gemacht ja das hat es zerstört anscheinend ne also das oh mann
was ist das denn das reboot das nach dem reboot geht das display nicht mehr was sehr sehr
merkwürdig ist was delete browser cookies ja ich wüsste jetzt erst mal wieder drauf
kommen überhaupt wisst ihr was ich mache einfach die ich mache einfach die anderen
auch wieder an und irgendeins davon wird er schon wird er schon dann schon da erscheinen
ich kann doch flaschen ich kann auch flaschen ist gar nicht das problem das display geht
nicht wieder an
das ärgert mich jetzt aber vor allem warum er kennt er denn jetzt gar nichts mehr ich
habe jetzt hier ich habe jetzt alle drei gleich an und hier rumliegen
aber das interessiert sich bluetooth am pc mal neu starten meinst du das bringt was habe
ich so meine zweifel aber können wir mal machen
guck mal jetzt habe ich da unten sogar ein bluetooth icon das hatte ich vorher nicht
muss ich vielleicht height an und aus machen da ist es koppeln bam ich weiß nicht warum
es jetzt funktioniert aber gut ich weiß nicht welches der drei jetzt ist übrigens
ne warte mal was habe ich habe das ich habe da irgendwas falsches auf
ich habe das ich habe das falsche auf ich habe die falsche seite auf
hier muss ich hin ok das ist jetzt das das ist jetzt das was
er detected hat das ist mein erstes das ist das eigentlich geprikte was er jetzt erkennt
das muss ich ausmachen ok 18 alle im arsch man ja das war es das richtige connect und
die anderen erkennt er gar nicht mehr
nachdem ich die dinge aus china habe heißt es ja im endeffekt auch
nachdem ich die dinge aus china habe heißt das die haben neueste firmware vielleicht
hier haben die irgendwelche anti anti prick dinger oder was
max ein emote wurde gelöscht das hatte ich doch gar nicht drin
modge wir hatten modge nie oder
restart noch mal noch mal bluetooth soll ja noch bluetooth stand da und den browser
ob ich aber nicht dass es was macht hier ist eins koppel ich weiß nicht welches der
bein das jetzt ist ich hier 125 ok jetzt connecte nicht mal mensch ja connected
moment das ist schon wieder das falsche
ist das richtige bin verwirrt ich bin ich bin verwirrt
ich bin verwirrt moment das ist das alte das ist das neue
was was war immer ok issue was ich hier 125 ok jetzt hab ich hier 125
ja das ist ja bei mir nicht so ich hab die original firmware geflasht und es ist
es ist brauchen immer noch brauchen woher weiß ich denn ob ich revision b habe
kann ich hier drüber ha
warum die dinger jetzt hier überhaupt nicht mehr auftauchen ist mir auch nicht klar
was am karton hinten stand was
gucke auf den karton hinten ob da was steht revision 2019
warum werden die dinger geflasht weil poggers weil die batterie länger hält also i have
the same problem with two units both have adas hab ich
after the display shows 88 and low and says the temperature
ob das hab ich
my first work so i ordered some more with you i have sample after flashing custom of
display freezes when i put battery out and back display stays empty but i'm able to connect
via web updater ja das problem habe ich auch
id 2019 dp ok da gucken wir mal kurz hinten drauf ob ich das auch hab
irgendwas wo ich vielleicht nicht hinten die rückseite zerrissen hab wäre mal ganz
gut gibt's natürlich nicht hab die rückseite überall auseinander gerobbt aber ich hab
ja ich hab ja noch welche hier wo hab ich dann hingelegt hier also rückseite
2007 dp 8 1 1 5 ist das das gleiche was der dude hat
dp 8 1 1 5 aha aha aha da kommen wir da kommen wir das sache näher putting out back display
stays empty but i'm able to connect via web updater ja das bin ich auch
wenn es dann mal funktioniert
wenn es denn mal funktioniert ich denke einfach ein neues und testes da
starte bluetooth neu
ok was machen die denn besitze display problem measurement does not work off
der sukzess für die connecte
aha ja das habe ich auch genau genau genau genau
lcd ic so that means we need to adapt the display communication what better image of
chip pictures would help most the chinese chips
ja auf aufschrauben tue ich das ding jetzt net oder
chat hört auf solche low iq messages zu schreiben meine das habe ich nicht alle schon tausend
mal gemacht meine ich komme nicht auf die idee mal die
batterie zu wechseln reine küde das ist doch kein totaler kack noob
router neu starten router router neu starten noch
ok wo sind wir router wo sind wir stehen geblieben aufschraub gel
die haben alle das gleiche hier guck mal
at least i found a way to recover haha click click
go to the job hope app was ok das mache ich jetzt aber nicht
das mache ich jetzt aber nicht die offizielle app
took a while to get it but we are here we go changed place
new film we are attached ok
next try ah
ok
mal gucken ob unbricken funktioniert da bin ich jetzt mal gespannt ich mach jetzt ich mach
jetzt einfach alle an alle die ich hab an und sobald was auftaucht wird
connected connect connect ich mach jetzt bei allen die batterie rein raus ich geh
ich hole die noch mal mit alle alle restarted
und dann starten wir mit chat heute auch noch mal bluetooth neu
was muss jetzt connection kriegen irgendwas davon muss connection kriegen
ok wir machen sogar zack
connect abwarten oder machen wir hier ist eigentlich egal dass ich ich kann ich kann
ruhig unbekannte geräte halten ich glaube das macht keinen unterschied abwarten
es wäre cool wenn das ding einen knopf hätte schieb doch mal dein nachbar auf ja ich schieb
dem nachbar mal kurz die firme auf den fernseher easy
also wenn die dinger sich jetzt nicht melden innerhalb von 1 2 minuten
dann werde ich einfach noch eins auspacken und wir flaschen mit der neuen firme ja
und die anderen prick und prick ich dann mal auf stream
uns da einprick wir können nicht prädikten leute wir können nicht prädikten cancel das
mal wenn er das nicht erkennt zählt das nicht das können wir nicht machen
das ist die original firme ja nee
ist das die original firme ja zack mal das muss ich mir jetzt angucken
so can we develop this now and for the first further ah moment
ist das die ist das die ach das ist die original firme ja
ach das ist die original firme ja das ist ja langweilig
ich weiß wenn ich mich jetzt mal connecten könnte könnte ich auch versuchen zu anpricken
doppeln welche auch immer das jetzt ist
connecting das sind wir ok das ist irgendwie ein neuer
das ist irgendwie einer von den neuen ok datei auswählen
ok oh
welcher ist das 22 das ist der im bad das ist der im bad ich habe mich gerade batterie
batterie nee ist das der im bad
das blick ich nicht mehr durch jetzt ist zu viel
moment ist das der im bad vielleicht software version 2.9 das muss der alte sein das muss
der alte sein wir haben wir haben 3.1 geflasht
ja nein nein das ist das falsche connect
also der hohen flipp aus im chat dann warten wir jetzt bis er die anderen erkennt
erstmal den bad blicken den den den den den bad mach ich nix der soll die mal erkennen
jetzt endlich mit der custom firme announced der halt
seltener was halt auch dazu führt dass die dass die dass es länger hält
die batterie aber da seht ihr es funktioniert prinzipiell
das ist hochgradig spannend dem jetzt zuzugucken wie er wieder die teile erkennt
schmeißt die alten geräte mal raus wo soll ich denn alte geräte rausschmeißen
wo gibt es hier überhaupt was zum rausschmeißen
nee das hat doch vorhin auch funktioniert nach dem neustart
rechtsklick auf bluetooth symbol du meinst das hier
nee hier ist nix gepaart
hier ist nix gepaart nee das hat vorhin auch funktioniert
nutzt du zigbee geräte ja ich hab nen kombi 2 aber ich hab nicht viele zigbee geräte
moment ich hab gedacht das geht einfacher
das hat doch eben nicht so lange gedauert naja jetzt ist auch die custom firme drauf
die custom firme ist halt standardmäßig schon langsamer mit den announcements
hat man da irgendwie ne history
ja chat ich glaube batterie raus und rein hilft bestimmt was
jetzt wieder zu reconnect ich drücke jetzt einfach reconnect was noch immer passiert
aber das braucht einfach so lang
eigentlich sollte er doch einmal beim starten wirklich announcen macht er aber nicht
keine ahnung vielleicht ist es auch irgendein bug im chrome vielleicht sind die doch unknown
das muss ja zumindest in namen podcasten hier
was ist denn eigentlich ah ja ich hab wirklich keine ahnung
probier mal edge
was mach ich jetzt ohne scheiß edge es war auch nur chrome aber wer weiß
ist genau das gleiche nur das fenster sieht ein bisschen anders aus
ja der nachbarfernseh poggers
experimental doch ist ansonsten würde das hier nicht funktionieren
a 4 c 138 ja es wird schon drinnen stehen aber
vorhin stand es ja auch drinnen
ich kann den fernseher nicht aus versehen flaschen der wird sich garantiert nicht so
drauf zugreifen lassen
das vom namen her würde ich sagen es ist ein samsung oder wahrscheinlich
das unbekannt
das war jetzt einfach zu fall das liegt nicht auf announ
jetzt habe ich den erwischt mit der mit der alten
jetzt habe ich den erwischt mit der alten zurück geflashten firmware
login successful
ok alles klar mit der alten stockfirmware
choose download
flasht der jetzt
start flashing
ok ich weiß nicht welcher von den geräten das hier ist ehrlich gesagt ich blicke
da gerade nicht mehr durch
ich sehe jetzt ja gleich ob eins davon wieder angeht oder näher weg machen keine
ja was ist was ist pricken das ist wenn ein gerät was funktioniert
ne krasse firmware drauf flasht und es danach nicht mehr geht
so hier sind sie hier sind sie ich zeig sie euch leute hier
ich kann jetzt gucken ob es da sind sie
wenn gleich eins angeht wissen wir bescheid
ich habe ja auch die falsche kasse die falsche original firmware zurückgeflasht
die für den alten controller
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
es ist auf jeden fall schon ziemlich lahm
die neue firmware ist pepo fett
82 83 84 85 96 97 88 89 90 91 92 93 94 95 96 97 98 99 dann
dazu kann ich nur sagen
ok das funktioniert schon mal
die anderen ein pricke ich auf stream leute ich glaube ihr habt keinen bock
jetzt für die anderen zwei geräte auch noch mal eine viertel stunde zu warten
bis sie entbringt sind ich mache jetzt einfach die batterie raus und
gut ist doch please lull
sieht aus wie mit original version das liegt daran das ist die original version
das ist die original version die du gerade gesehen hast
ich habe ein gerät gekauft aus china oder zehn geräte aus china die haben eine
neue revision die mit der custom firme nicht funktioniert siehe hier und das ist die das
ist die neue firmware die neue offizielle firmware wenn man die zurückflasht geht's
wieder
ich hoffe es gibt was neues dann weil jetzt kann ich die überhaupt nicht
verwenden das ist ziemlich sätke
also ich meine ich habe jetzt wieder funktionierende geräte aber ich habe keine geflashte firmware
und das ist dumm weil ich will die ja mit geflashter firmware
betreiben ohne geflashte firme ist useless für mich dafür hast du pro gerät fünf
euro gespart ja das stimmt und ich gehe mal davon aus oder ich hoffe mal dass
sie das hier hinbekommen weil er sagt ja auch update downgrade works fine so so
can be developed with now and reverse further ja dann dann viel viel viel spaß
beim reversen ich hoffe ich hoffe die machen dass ich meine prinzip sind es
ja alles nur freiwillige leute aber ich hoffe das wird das wird jetzt mit der
zeit kommt das also es kann durchaus sein ich habe halt echt pech hätte ich vor
einem monat bestellt hätte ich wahrscheinlich noch die alte revision
gekriegt kannst du net original downgrade und dann die custom nee also ja kann ich
machen habe ich ja gemacht aber das bringt nix weil die custom firmware hat
den verrat in falschen ich würde mal sagen so eine art falschen display
treiber drin die haben nämlich den controller für das display ausgetauscht
in der letzten revision und die custom firmware auf github die verwendet halt
noch zum spricht dann noch den alten display controller an
ja schön dass du da bist wo du tag danke für den sub du hast jetzt einen
kicks in holz für 3 jetzt die hartware hat sich geändert richtig die hartware
hat sich geändert und die custom firmware ist für die alte hartware was
meinen die github user mit downgrade 03 ja das was ich gerade gemacht habe quasi
auf die achso ne gut das weiß ich nicht was sie damit meinen also hier die meinen
du achso ja das da ist die custom firmware
aber das problem ist dass das display halt dann nicht geht
du kannst von und zu custom firmware version 0 1 3 0 oder was auch immer ach
nee hier das ist die neue offizielle firmware ja also du kannst updaten dahin
und du kannst downcreate von der custom firmware zu der um dein device zu
unpricken aber es bringt ja halt nichts weil die custom firmware den falschen
display controller anspricht
sprichst du da das an nein ich meine die bett stehen bei deinem
namen das da guckt du hast jetzt ein keks in holz für ersten monat
subscription der baumeister dee du hast kein keks in holz der
meine güte ei warum ist das china chinesen zeug immer so kompliziert es
ist 21 auf 50 leute ich glaube wir kommen heute nicht mehr zu den
tasmotas steckdosen da würde ich sagen müssen wir morgen noch mal
bastel stream so machen oder was sagt ihr
holpriger bastel stream
übrigens richtig viele leute für bastel stream heute da richtig richtig
nice dass ihr alle da seid ich überlege gerade können wir noch
irgendwas ausprobieren zum jetzigen zeitpunkt damit erst mal schauen ob die
steckdosen auch gleich geblieben sind jetzt mal mal den teufel nicht an die
wand
irgendwas anderes bricken ja wir haben fort 20 zuschauer exzellent
ja was könnte ich den anderes noch pricken auf die schnelle
hält mir jetzt nichts ein
ja weil du so viel streams mag dich twitch in letzter zeit öfters empfehlen
exquisite könnte natürlich auch sein dass es daran liegt den lasse ich hier
mal zu jetzt moment wisst ihr was ich gucke mal durch ob das alles die neueste
revision ist vielleicht sind da ja welche mit der alten revision dabei
seck guck mal mal durch guck mal mal durch schnell also die bricht bricht ist
die hier
bricht ist die hier die 2019 seht ihr es hier 2019 dp 8 115 ist kaputt
wir überprüfen das noch mal ob das auch stimmt
dp ja 2019 dp 8 8 8 1 1 5 ok dann gucken wir mal die anderen durch wie
sieht es dann damit aus dp 8 1 1 5
dp 8 1 1 5
rege dp 8 1 1 5 ich fürchte wir haben keine guten chancen hier
2 stück haben wir noch dp 8 1 1 5
dp 8 1 1 5 ok
leider nix dabei
sätge richtig sätge ist das
sätge
da macht sie nix und guck mal was liegt denn hier es ist der abisoliert schimpf
weiß nicht warum der hier liegt normalerweise sollte an der werkzeug wand
hängen gastauftritt des abisoliert schäms was
machen wir denn jetzt nix nix soll man machen
das soll man machen holzfelle hemd am start ja hemd soar und hier katze
katzenkratzer rumtour ist klar auf geht's wir machen rumtour easy
echt du hast die gleiche all die das heißt anhand der all die erkennt man
das gar nicht wenn man das anhand der all die nicht erkennt ist aber durft da
müsste ich die aufschrauben da müsste ich die aufschrauben und bord revision
gucken was sind das für schrauben zeigt mal hier was zum teufel ist das denn
für china chinesen zeug noch ein aufschrauben
immer noch ein aufschrauben und reingucken produktionsdatum ganz unten
wo ist das produktionsdatum ja 2021 ok das sind die das sind die neun 2021
2021 2021 hätte ich mal was hätte ich mal hätte ich
mal vor ein zwei monat bestellt 2021 2021 2021 leute einer fehlt mir einer
fehlt guckt mal hier 1 2 3 1 1 2 hier so einer 2021 ok 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 7 und das 3
ne es ist alles 2021 leider keine chance das ist ja sehr richtig richtig sehr
da müssen wir auch nicht raufschrauben die müssen wir auch nicht aufschrauben
und reingucken hat keinen sinn dass wenn die wenn die jetzt produziert dann sind
die das weil ich habe keine ahnung was das hier für eine komische schraube ist
bei den von den china chinesen guckt euch das mal an brauche ich irgendwie mal
licht drauf aber dann geht es an die kamera aber hier china chinesen schraube
keine ahnung was es sein soll mini talks für arme hat das flaschen
geflaschen geklappt ja und nein das flaschen hat geklappt aber ich habe es
kaputt geflasht und dann habe ich wieder die originalfirmware nach größerem
akt drauf geflasht und dann geht es wieder soll ich komme ich guck mal ob ich
nicht ob ich was hab zum aufschrauben ich hole man ich hab ich hab mir doch
vielleicht habe ich mir nicht umsonst dieses i-fix-it toolkit gekauft
was richtig richtig poggers ist ich habe mir ich habe in meinem serverraum jetzt
einen bewegungs melder und den habe ich verbunden 3d drucker zeug oder staub
keine ahnung und den habe ich verbunden mit meinem home assistant und wenn ich
jetzt in den serverraum drüben reingehe dann geht automatisch die rgb
die rgb nicht die rgb die led birne an der decke an da machen wir das mal auf
und gucken ob wir da irgendwas dabei haben wo wir das china chinesen zeug mit
aufkriegen erst mal bis sie platz machen hier erst mal ein bisschen platz
machen china chinesen zeug aufmachen so also diesen ganzen schitt hier braucht
man nicht man braucht eigentlich nur den da was könnte denn hiervon passen meint
ihr da passt irgendwas von chat seid ihr big brain genug welcher passt ich
wüsste es jetzt nicht das da sowas hier in der richtung
sowas hier so mini mini talks
das ist noch zu groß wir brauchen micro micro talks aha aha aha ich glaube das
ist noch eins zu groß eins zu groß
passt passt leute
chinesen chinesen china talks
taub das wieder hier so haben wir das mal weg einen platz machen
china chinesen den mal aufschrauben
sag
kommt mal dafür sind die fächer wirklich praktisch und hopp
nachkommen raus so und jetzt und jetzt geht es nicht weiter auf super das wäre
doch mal ein projekt für den stream wie weit bist du eigentlich mit einem
heizungsprojekt funktioniert jetzt soweit ich habe das auf stream
auf stream fertig gemacht so also wie kriegt man jetzt weiter auf ich
habe jetzt die schrauben raus gemacht und jetzt und jetzt irgendwie aufhebeln
oder so und jetzt gewalt
man muss da bestimmt bestimmt irgendwie klipsen oder so ganz schlechte idee ganz
schlechte idee ich habe es auf man muss so wirklich mit
gewalt reinpixeln dass es funktioniert ok china chinesen zeug
das hat da irgendwie fleck seht ihr den fleck
da haben die fließband chinesen drauf gespuckt
wobei ich habe gelesen die chinesen machen das gar nicht mehr selbst
umso menschenverachtender die arbeit ist überlassen sie das jetzt auch ganz
gern nordkoreanern den nix anderes übrig bleibt dark dark mode ja das war
eine blöde idee das muss ich jetzt mal gucken dass ich das nicht nicht
komplett nicht komplett zerstöre so das ist vorne die abdeckung das ist das
display und das ist irgendwie so ein abstandshalter ok also hier platinen
revision
hw a das ist das was die typen geschrieben haben guckt mal da unten die
zahl das ist das was die geschrieben haben b bl 6 hw bl 6 das haben die auf
github geschrieben das ist das ding was davon betroffen ist man sieht mal dass
da relativ wenig relativ wenig zeugs drauf ist da ist so gut wie keine
technik drauf da ist da ist fast nix das ist ein
batterienhalter das hier ist wahrscheinlich der der
controller oder so und das kann ich nicht lesen da drauf steht da ist nicht da ist
nicht viel drinnen aber an die musik wieder was soll auch groß drinnen weiß
nicht den habe ich so aufgemacht was sind das für dinge das sind
temperatur luftfeuchtigkeit sensoren fürs bad soll mal gucken ob ich das jetzt
wieder zusammen kriege so also das display muss ja wahrscheinlich so hin
weil das display muss hier unten drauf vermute ich mal also so hier auf die
kontakte so
display muss so auf die kontakte oh das ist das ist feinfühlig das wieder
zusammenzusetzen das ist äußerst äußerst äußerst feinfühlig
das baue ich jetzt nicht zusammen wenn ich das jetzt zusammenbauen am meisten
kaputt ich sage es euch leute dann ist dann ist broken also ich gehe mal davon
aus dass es so rum so rum drauf muss so und dann muss man es wahrscheinlich hier
wieder reinsetzen
irgendwie wahrscheinlich so rum ich vermute mal so rum oder ja ich glaube ich
glaube so rum
das muss man wahrscheinlich der reihe nach einsortieren so wie es so wie es
passt irgendwie zuerst den da aber das lustige ist ich glaube der passt in alle
richtungen oder nieder passt nicht in alle richtungen guckt mal
da passt fast in alle richtungen keck weight
das mache ich jetzt das mache ich jetzt aber nicht das mache ich das mache ich
das mache ich kaputt wenn ich das wenn ich das jetzt hier so zusammen wusste
doch das krieg ich schon wieder zusammen also ich denke das muss wirklich genau
so wie ich sie habe das zuerst dann gefolgt dann irgendwie gefolgt vom
display da müsste jetzt halt mal gucken wie rum das display das hätte ich mir
jetzt halt vorher mal angucken müssen wie rum das display da reinkommt weil das
display passt in in alle in alle richtungen rein aber ich vermute mal dass
dieses teil hier nicht in alle richtungen reinpasst
naja naja
das sieht in der tat ganz gut aus und jetzt so rum Leute ich glaube ich hab's
ist wieder da ist wieder zusammen easy so wo sind die chinesen torx schrauben ob
ich jetzt richtig drin habe wird sich zeigen aber aber in der regel wenn sich
der kram komplett mühelos zusammensetzen lässt ist das meistens schon mal ein
guter indikator für dass es stimmt und ich habe das bord auf jeden fall auch
richtig auf die display kontakte immer auch das ist falsch
leute
kipp falsch falsch rum das war ich heute nicht habe ich keinen bock drauf das
gucke ich mir morgen in ruhe an ohne stream das war ich morgen ich wollte
eigentlich bloß mal reingucken ist auch schon spät ja so sieht's aus
was macht eigentlich der frazier
spielter weep games
yesterday hat er weep games gespielt ja ja so gibt es irgendjemand den wir
hosten können das solution spiel immer noch fifa
mag wie fand ich
einer darin mich folge der auch brauchen würde
älter steiner rein der hat bestimmt 50 millionen zuschauer der braucht das
nicht was pc tom wer ist pc tom twitch pc tom
macht er da wir versuchen einen drum herum zu bohren
was das sieht aus wie von 1995 was er da hat und warum ist es asterix und obelix xxl3
also ich gucke mal kurz was hier in der kategorie so abgeht moment just just
chatting ist die falsche kategorie was erwerbung science and technology live
earth quakes alles klar die das stark
den kenne ich von youtube der kommt mir bekannt vor
wer ist denn wie heißen diese wie heißen diese programmierkategorie noch
mal weiß das jemand das ist doch jetzt neu software software and game
development hier am start auch niemand genau wie wir hosten einfach montana
black mit 95 grad zuschauer easy der braucht das ganze bestimmt ach ich weiß
es nicht
ich hause heute keine scherz ins bettke leute wupp bettke
bettke
warum sind die subs so billig sollten die nicht 4 euro kosten september ist doch
vorbei
warum ist die message jetzt weg aber das ist ein automatischer filter
weiß ich was daran so schlimm ist dass man das dass man das filtern muss aber
ok alles klar heute wir sehen uns bis morgen oder so mal gucken aber ich glaube
wir machen morgen weiter bis denn macht es gut zu